on ne sait pas si ce mouvement venu du
canada va arriver comme vous le disiez
aux états unis mais il arrive en tout
cas déjà en france avec le même objectif
dénoncer les restrictions sanitaires duo
kobe 19 et pour se faire entendre les
participants entendent bien rejoindre
paris est perturbé la circulation dès
vendredi soir pour en parler on retrouve
emily goog h bonsoir emilie c'est au
départ de plusieurs villes françaises
que des convois sont donc partis dès ce
matin
bonsoir stéphanie absolument vous allez
le voir grâce à cette carte qui a été
publié sur la page facebook officielle
convoy france officielle elle est
importante car elle elle montre que tout
a été méticuleusement organisé ce qu'on
voit ce sont donc tous les trajets prévu
depuis aujourd'hui il ya aussi des
villes étapes par exemple où passer la
nuit il faut savoir que les départs
n'ont pas lieu en même temps mais sur
trois jours avec donc plusieurs
itinéraires tout d'abord depuis les
villes les plus éloignés de la capitale
à savoir nice perpignan ou encore
bayonne ça c'était donc aujourd'hui
demain ce sera au tour des villes dites
à distance intermédiaire comme brest et
bordeaux et enfin vendredi lé convoi au
départ deux villes proches de paris
pourront donc partir notamment depuis
lille tours ou encore strasbourg par
exemple et le but est donc d'arriver à
paris dès vendredi soir emilie est ce
qu'on va voir de gros camion bloqué la
capitale comme au canada
alors à priori stéphanie les images ne
seront peut-être pas aussi
impressionnante car en france les poids
lourds appartiennent rarement aux
chauffeurs eux mêmes mais plutôt à des
sociétés privées il risquerait donc
peut-être des amendes résultat on aura
sans doute plus tendance à avoir des
voitures ou encore des deux roues il y
aura bien sûr quelques camions c'est
certain pour ce qui est de la
mobilisation elle se veut plutôt forte à
en croire une page facebook intitulée le
convoi de la liberté qui compte ce soir
pas moi de 316 1000 membres alors tous
nos seront pas sur les routes mais pour
ceux qui soutiennent le mouvement il
s'agit de faire entendre leur
exaspération face vous l'avais dit aux
restrictions sanitaires et encore plus
au pass vaccinale écoutez justement ces
manifestants qui sont venus soutenir un
convoi parti tout à l'heure de bayonne
on est en train de soutenir le convoi
des libertés
on a été tellement heureux de voir ce
qui se passait au canada et de voir ce
qui se passe maintenant en europe dans
le monde on vient soutenir tous ceux qui
vont partir pour nos libertés il a fallu
être responsable moi je suis allé
travailler les trois confinement j'ai
attrapé le coc vide au travail et voilà
et derrière ça avant j'étais un héros de
la nation maintenant je suis même plus
un citoyen donc je comprends pas comment
on est passé de laruns à l'autre il
demande donc à pouvoir retrouver si la
liberté liberté face aux restrictions
sanitaires et notamment donc on l'a dit
face aux passes vaccinale en particulier
c'est pour cette raison que les
participants au convoi compte donc
rouler sur paris ce week end très ml
justement comment on réagit en
particulier du côté de la préfecture de
police de paris ou encore du côté des
politiques
dans ces familles ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que la préfecture de police de
paris suit cette mobilisation un
dispositif de détection de blocage des
accès à l'île de france et à la capitale
et un dispositif de verbalisation seront
bien sûr mis en place je cite la
préfecture de police interrogé par nos
confrères de france info autre réaction
celle du ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin selon lui aucun renseignement
ne laisse penser que la mobilisation
sera forte mais il assure tout de même
que les moyens seront importants pour
prévenir d'éventuels blocages et puis
enfin il ya la réaction de gabriella tél
qui dit comprendre la lassitude des
français mais il explique aussi que nos
restrictions sont parmi les plus les
moins contraignantes et goûter
on sait qu'il ya une fatigue une fatigue
et de lassitude des français vis-à-vis
de ce virus et des mesures que nous
avons dû prendre depuis le début de
cette crise pour protéger les français
il ya plus que quelques centaines de
milliers de personnes qui en ont marre
de cette épidémie qui en ont marre de
vivre avec ce virus est le plus début de
cette crise en france comme partout dans
le monde des mouvements politiques
souvent radicaux ont cherché à
capitaliser sur cette lassitude et cette
fête et cette fatigue pour essayer de
créer des mouvements moi ce que je veux
rappeler c'est que quand vous revenez
quelques semaines ou quelques mois en
arrière la france est probablement l'un
des pays d'europe qui a pris le moins de
mesures contraignantes le moins de
mesures qui entravent la liberté de ses
concitoyens ce sont bien les entraves à
la liberté que veut en tout cas dénoncé
ce mouvement qui n'a pas seulement
atteint la france si le premier point de
chute et donc paris dès ce vendredi les
convois la liberté compte ensuite
atteindre bruxelles dès lundi prochain
un mouvement donc qui s'exporte depuis
le canada et qui n'est pas sans rappeler
celui des gilet jaune dont beaucoup de
membres soutiennent d'ailleurs ces
convois de la liberté merci mg je
pensais précision